hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
christmas kraft teil
3 richtig andré schmidt gewählt ihr seht
oben wieder die sachen eingeblendet da
ist ein schwein gerade uns was der bau
vorschlag von zocken ohne verstand sehr
schöner name
er meint ich soll ein
weihnachtsplätzchen bauen ich denke ich
werde mehrere bauen weil 1 ist ein
bisschen wenig und themen vorschlag
kommt von 14 nick 14 14 1 ca 14
dem vorschlag was wolltest du früher
haben was willst du jetzt haben also
wahrscheinlich zu weihnachten
na ja dann würde ich mal sagen ich mache
das hier ähnliches so dass wieder mal
sind so hallo hier bin ich falsch genug
so also erstmal ein weihnachtsplätzchen
was brauchen wir für ein
weihnachtsplätzchen
ich würde sagen auf jeden fall braune
wolle und da sind auch oft so komisch
eingravieren darin sag ich mal
ich denke mir braucht man gar nicht ich
versuch's mal wieder das blöde minecraft
wenn man weihnachtsplätzchen bauen will
dann müssen die menschen richtig groß
sein
das heißt ich sport und man einfach hier
so einzelnen denke ich ja hier so gut
während ich am bauen wenn ich mach das
mal ganz bisschen leiser so während ich
am baum bin kann ich ja dann einfach ein
bisschen quatschen und zwar über das
thema was wollte ich früher haben was
will ich jetzt haben warten muss man
ganz kurz aus zählen 1 2 3 4 5 78
246 18 muss bereits dann wenn ich mir
das so forsche ja keine ahnung was
wirklich damals haben
ich war schon immer eine person sage ich
mal
die man auch mit kleinen dingen sage ich
mal zufrieden stellen konnte wenn ich
mich jetzt so richtig ausgedrückt habe
also wenn ich ich wünsche mir nicht viel
zu weihnachten aber wenn schon so eine
sache die dann schon so ein bisschen
größer ist also ich wünsch mir sicher
das spiel und dann dies und dann hier
noch da etwas und so sondern das ist
schon bei mir so dass ich mir so eine
sache wünsche und die wünsche dann
bekomme ich das dann auch meistens und
ich glaube dass finden meine eltern auch
ganz gut dass ich da nicht so sehen wir
zehn milliarden sachen wünschen wenn ich
eine sache nicht bekomme dann lass dich
übels außen sollte ich glaube dass also
bin ich halt nicht und das finde ich
auch eigentlich ganz gut aber das war
eine andere frage und zwar was wünsche
ich mir damals und was wünsche ich mir
heute gut im moment hab grad keine zeit
ich nehme auf was ja okay ich hab grad
ich was ich gemacht habe oder ob ich das
einfach drin gelassen habe das war mein
vater der meint die sind jetzt weg und
ich soll um 7 uhr noch mal holz im kamin
nachlegen ok cool es ist nämlich gerade
halb sieben na ja das sieht ein bisschen
man erkennt auf gar keinen fall dass das
links ist ich mach das man muss ein
bisschen höher moment ich mache mir
einfach ja also früher habe ich mir so
sachen von von playmobil und lego immer
ganz gern gewünscht weil ich lego und
playmobil mal richtig geil fand weil das
war jetzt nicht so einfach ich fand das
immer kacke wenn man einfach so ein
spielzeug bekommen hat und dann hat man
weg ist ein spielzeug gehabt in einem
auto sondern ich will mir das wenn schon
selber zusammenbauen es hat zwei
meistens nicht funktioniert bei so
komischen lego hydraulik sachen das kann
auch einzelne aber sonst war das
eigentlich immer ganz cool und ich habe
mich halt immer über lego ganz gut
gefreut bzw
also wenn schon muss das was von lego
oder playmobil sein
und mittlerweile ist es so dass ich mir
halt letztes jahr zum beispiel was ich
war einfach noch ein ich bin jetzt drei
minuten ist dabei mittlerweile ist es so
dass ich paulas ein bisschen hier hinten
in wissen dann sieht man die von
dahinten auch das ist ja mal geil gute
idee lukas klocker 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
und mittlerweile ist es so dass ich mir
halt meistens elektronische sachen
wünsche es ja ganz klar
oder halt irgendwie geld von von oma und
opa oder sowie hat keine ahnung von
irgendwelchen elektronischen sachen
haben aber da dies ganz einfach der
grund weil mittlerweile brauche ich so
was auch für youtube sage ich mal
und das heißt youtube also will was ich
mehr zur zeit ich sage einfach was ich
mir dieses jahr zu weihnachten wünsche
und zwar wünsche ich mir dieses jahr
einen midi controller wenn ihr nicht
wisst was das ist das ist ein
ich sag mal ein schlagzeug allerdings
elektronisches mit touch tasten signal
und das vergleichen von der größe her
von der größe her ist das so wie ich sag
mal wie groß ist die controller ich
meine wo man kann ich das vergleiche mit
special stellen da sage ich mir ich
glaube alle von euch kennen
wäscheständer außerdem die flächen die
beim aber irgendwie zugedrückt hat wenn
die selber sehr traurig wenn das noch
nie gemacht hat na ja so ein
wäscheständer mit den maßen wo es aber
egal jedenfalls hinterhalt ganz viele
knöpfe sondern so touchpads wirklich
drauf ist und so soft sachen da kann man
drauf drückt dann kommen sound so in
geht das beim ein- oder beim andere ist
dass solche sachen am ende des 1 damit
ist oftmals kommt datendiensten sowas
dann raus also man kann damit sage ich
mal richtige beats erstellen das wünsche
ich mir das wünsche ich mir schon seit
einem halben jahr mittlerweile habe ich
aber nie irgendwie bin ich nicht dazu
gekommen das zu kaufen weil sein ding
wirklich ich teile sollen teils locker
200 300 euro oder so das ist eigentlich
ganz cool weil ich gerne auch mal sowie
zu erstellen könnte reicht das bisher
nur mit fl studio gemacht habe und dann
komme ich jetzt nicht ganz so supertoll
klar die bi zahlt sich jetzt eher nicht
so toll an also ist er nicht so mein
geschmack und außerdem wenn wir
weiterhin videoaufnahmen machen also ihr
wisst ja dass ich mit theresa und
jonathan die namen sollten wir sind
mittlerweile bekannt sein habe ich
sachen aufgenommen also hearings video
offen dann wartet das bäuchlein kurzem
zu nein das möchte ich nein das möchte
ich und dafür ist das eigentlich ganz
cool dass ich dann so im hintergrund
sage ich mal
das spielen kann also mit mini
controller so ein bisschen rum handeln
kann
das ist da bestimmt ganz cool übrigens
noch bitte keinen stress mit den
nächsten videos mit jonathan theresa wir
haben schon das nächste video
aufgenommen dass videos auch schon
also ich hab noch nicht angefangen das
zuschneiden aber es ist halt schon im
kasten alles aufgenommen
allerdings ist nur die sache wir wollen
jetzt nicht sofort wieder ein video
hochladen sage ich mal ganz einfach aus
dem grund weil wir
natürlich so ein bisschen ich sag mal
denn jetzt direkt an nächstes video
hochladen kommen ganz viele leute an und
dann wenn dann mal als ich sag mal wenn
wir das jetzt hochladen würden heute
dann wäre das eine woche direkt nach dem
ersten ziemlich genau dann wird in einer
woche wieder leute ein combo bleibt das
sieht diesen rhythmus gewohnt es ist
genauso wie bei let's play wenn ich mal
drei vier tage teilen nächste hochwasser
kommt leute an hey wo bleibt das nächste
video und wenn so ein typ der wenig
hochlädt wie zum beispiel renault trucks
oder julians blog wenn die mal paar
tagen wieder machen mit dabei war dass
bei den eher selten der fall ist
das heißt sollen video wenn wir das
hochladen soll das special seien
deswegen mache ich das jetzt nicht
einfach so direkt wieder so also das
wünsche ich mir dieses jahr so ein midi
controller
ich hatte noch einen wunsch und war
also diese habe ich echt viele wünsche
für meine verhältnisse sage ich mal was
wünsche ich mir dann noch was ich noch
mal kurz darauf mann ich hab den allem
einem handy eingegeben
ich könnte mal ganz kurz mein handy
nehmen moment hatte wo bist du denn da
er dann wünsche ich mir eine lampe von
ikea
also das ist so eine coole lampe das ist
nicht so eine blöde sterile lasse triste
lampe sondern die ich schon cool sage
ich mal also wollte ich noch mal hier
sagt dass jetzt eine falle geht gar
nicht weil ich das so und so
das ist schon so eine coole lampe und
zwar hat diesen komischen ring und ist
so wie beim zahnarzt nicht wie ein
zahnarzt und lampe sondern die schon
cooler und zwar sind die alt auslösung
ich liebe altmodische dinge wie zum
beispiel etwa 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
wie zum beispiel in alten braunen sessel
oder so finde ich super geil habe ich
auch in meinem zimmer stehen und ich
liebe einfach so altmodische dinge ich
habe auch hier ein teppich ich wollte
mir bald noch so ein bücherregal kaufen
weil ich einfach findet dass es extrem
geil aus die zu altmodische abstrakte
dinge finde ich nicht richtig hammer aus
also da wünsche ich mir so eine lampe
dann wünsche ich mir dass ich eine wand
in meinem zimmer schwarz streichen darf
also dass ich die genehmigung habe sage
ich mal ich will auch selber machen
am geilsten natürlich wenn ich
weihnachten nach hause kommen dann ist
hier sonne so eine wand schwarz
gestrichen dass wir jetzt unbedingt
wichtig er seine schwarze wand und was
damit machen wir werdet ihr dann noch
irgendwann später erfahren wenn ich sie
denn habe versteht ihr sonst noch so
drauf kommen primex coleman primax 190
das ist ein stativ für meine canon eos
600d kamera und zwar auch ja wenn wir
wenn wir aufwachen wir werden bald auch
mehr kurzfilme drehen für die schule
also es gibt das im wettbewerb da kann
man irgendwie von irgendeinem
unternehmen glaube ich 1000 euro oder so
gewinnen 1000 euro gutschein über video
equipment und ich mache das mit zwei
freunden und eventuell welches sie bei
kontrast auch noch mal so ein bisschen
ich sag mal
kommoden also dass ich euch das kurz
erklären was es ist kurz vorstellen wenn
ihr wollt könnt ihr land für uns
abstimmen bei seinem wettbewerb ist das
und der gewinner krieg 1000 euro video
equipment es wert ganz geil dann könnte
ich das alles hier im video aufnahme
setzen und die kumpels mit ich das mache
die als roman- und freddy aber schon
gesagt dass die das so halbwegs geben
würden weil die damit natürlich nichts
anfangen können weil die keine videos
machen aber die sind halt netterweise
als schauspieler mit dabei so dass wir
von ihm zu einfach
nein weg plüschschwein ihr so weiter
aber noch wenig sagen hierhin noch da
sind wir quasi eingekehrt von solchen
riesen links und diesen riesen teilen
lebkuchen dingens bowmans mein handy
bimmelt weil mir jemand bei fällt mein
herz schnauze facebook schreibt sie so
also diesel
das ist ein stativ für die kamera für
meine canon eos 600d das wünsche ich mir
auf jeden fall heute versteht ihr sonst
noch so eine halte denkst für die kamera
also ich www ages sind viele wünsche
aber das sind nicht wünsch die ich mir
alle zweien achten wünsche da wünsche
ich merke ich nur dass nur die lampe
dass die wand streichen und die midi
controller aber das sind alles sachen
die ich mir immer mal wieder auf streife
sachen die ich gerne haben würde und da
wünsche ich mir auch so einhalte teil
für die kamera so ein die hens mit fx
oder irgendwie sowas ist das display
das ist ein gerät das ist ein schulter
stativ nennt man das da kann man die
canon draufsetzen und da sind quasi an
wer an den halter teilen von den kennen
also ist es so verstehen eine
spiegelreflexkamera hatte er ein
objektiv woran man dann schärfe bei
stellen heran zoomen et cetera alles
einstellen kann und diese sachen sind
der mann schulter stativ hat muss man
immer so komisch an die kamera greifen
und an diesem ding sind zu schaumstoff
sachen so blaue schaumstoff sachen da
muss man einfach nur ein bisschen fester
drücken und dann zoomt der automatischen
beziehungsweise verstellt die blende
diese werte kann man auch direkt daran
wird verstellen direkt während der
aufnahme des super wahrscheinlich
verstehen dass gerade einige von euch
nicht aber auf jeden fall eine super
geile erfindung kostet allerdings 170
euro verzichtet heute findet wegen habe
ich mir das einfach mal aufgeschrieben
eventuell werde
mehr davon weil ein ähnliches den kaufen
die sachen sehen aus wie uno karten naja
und warte mein letzter wunsch moment des
abends meckert das war schon so dass war
selbst schon ne menge also das sind so
sachen die ich mir wünsche dann halte
das übliche halt jahren pulli und so
also und vor allem was ich da nur sagen
könnte ein wunschzettel ist kein
bestellzettel das sagen euch eure eltern
wahrscheinlich auch mal aber das ist
einfach so und zwar solltet ihr jetzt
nicht alles mögliche draufschreiben von
links ja da hätte ich gerne und die
kekse aus dem aldi und alles so komische
sachen sondern schon denken dass eure
eltern das als er noch bezahlen müsse
noch ein bisschen an eure eltern denken
so als wort zum sonntag sage ich mal
na ja meine damen herren wir haben ja
diese tollen lebkuchen plätzchen gebaut
danke an socken oder verstand für den
für den vorschlag und an 14 14
für den themenvorschlag schreibt mir
weiterhin themenvorschläge und bau
vorschläge in die kommentare eventuell
auch ein paar lustige geschichten weil
dann könnt ihr am zehnten also in genau
einer woche könnt ihr dann geschenke
gewinn unterwegs sagen sehen uns beim
nächsten mal schau